there was kind of a wrestling match of
sorts in Alabama it was an earthquake
you could say they're traditionally
Republican state of Alabama surprised
the world by electing a Democratic
senator doug jones narrowly defeated Roy
Moore in yesterday's special election
now the Republican candidate told his
supporters it's not over after race
where Moore was outspent and accused of
pursuing teenaged girls while he was in
his 30s Jones won with forty nine point
nine percent of the vote a lead of about
one and a half percentage points or
about twenty thousand votes in his
victory speech Jones said his wind sends
a message to the world
Manuel Bojorquez is in Birmingham
Alabama where the Democrats celebrated
last night man well good morning good
morning President Trump tweeted last
night congratulating Democrat Doug Jones
on a quote hard-fought victory in this
deeply red state a win by Jones seemed
highly unlikely and the president would
know he won Alabama last year by nearly
30 points last night even Doug Jones
seemed surprised by his unlikely win we
have so not just around the state of
Alabama but we have shown the country
the way that we
Jones opponent Republican Roy Moore
blamed his defeat on allegations of
sexual misconduct that dogged his
campaign for weeks part of the problem
with this campaign is we've been painted
in an unfavorable and unfaithful light
he declined to concede believing an
automatic recount was possible and
that's what we've got to do is wait on
God and let this process play out
according to CBS exit polling more than
half of voters said the allegations
against Moore were true and Jones found
strong support among African Americans
women and younger voters the big story
was turnout in counties where doug jones
did well turnout was up over
expectations but Republicans seemed to
stay home turnout was down in reliably
read Republican counties
president Trump rallied support for more
in the final days of his campaign along
with former White House chief strategist
Steve Bannon judge Moore's a righteous
man who championed Moore as part of his
war on Washington I'll tell you that
didn't vote for him some blamed Alabama
Senator Richard Shelby for Moore's
defeat including supporters we spoke
with last night
[Music]
the write-in campaigns maybe one of the
factors that cost more the election
nearly 2% of votes or ride ins which
covers Doug Jones margin of victory
as for the recount Moore is hoping for
Alabama state law calls for one but only
of the margin of victory is less than
1/2 of 1% Jones won by about three times
that Gail Wow thank you very much Manuel
Baracus